What is the phrase women in tech?
The phrase women in tech is something that's relatively new and I think most importantly it addresses the fact that there is a disparity between the amount of women who are in what would be considered technical roles and what might not be considered technical roles.
And in that sense it's quite inclusion based but can potentially nod to the inequality in the industry.
I feel in line with what you've said. Although for me women in tech just means, there's two ways I see, I look at it.
Women in tech means more work needs to be done so that it's not called women in tech anymore, it's called people in tech.
And the second thing when it says women in tech it just gives me a sense of tribal community that we have each other supporting each other, lifting each other up.
So it could go both ways for me when you say women in tech.
I really like that perspective of it being a community within a community.
I think that's something that, a solidarity between women I find really powerful and that I think brings the inclusion.
Do you feel supported when you hear that phrase or us sat here talking like this, do you feel supported?
I do, yeah. Even when we attend some conferences and there's all these women from different backgrounds but they're part of the world of tech.
And like you said, we know that there is gender disparity in this field.
And then to see that we're helping each other get to, with the support of the other gender as well.
It's not necessarily that it's all just women. There's so many men who are a part of women in tech as well.
But the fact that everyone's getting together and have acknowledged the fact that there is a big gap and we're working towards reducing that gap is just really nice and heartwarming.
That's interesting that you mentioned that it's not just about women as well, because I suppose the fact that women in tech has become this term, whether or not it means anything to you, even if it was started by say a woman who maybe didn't feel so included, the men on the other side who have recognised this divide, the fact that the term has become so widely known means that they will be supporting it and doing something about it as well.
I think it's so important as well to have men supporting it because how can a minority bring themselves up to the level of the majority without the help of the majority?
There's no way that we can push past the glass ceiling without the men looking down, giving us a hand up.
Yeah, agreed.
I kind of think it's context dependent, whether it's a buzzword or not. But whether it is or not, I think it's for a good reason when used appropriately.
It's definitely not one of those phrases like, let's touch base. I mean, that means nothing to me anymore.
But women in tech, when I hear that, it does mean something. And if it's used appropriately, I feel it can be very powerful.
That's really interesting. Because it is, it has kind of become a buzzword. I think it's applied to, like your point about context, I think it's applied sometimes in situations where it potentially doesn't need to be mentioned.
And it's used in that sense to, I think, essentially say, we've got women here, so we're fine. We've checked our diversity question or whatever. But in itself, I don't find it, I suppose. No, I don't think I do think it's a buzzword. I don't think.
I think context is really important. Because when you think about things like International Women's Day, we're going to hear the phrase women in tech from left, right and centre today. And I think that in that context, it really dilutes the idea of women in tech. When it's used all year round, not so much.
That's really interesting. Make it a year round concept. Yeah, it's not just for a day. Yeah, it's not just International Women's Day.
It doesn't, the issues that women face in the tech industry don't disappear on March the 9th. And then start off again. Really? Yeah.
I think it's so important to have this as a focus all year round. That stops it from becoming a buzzword for me. I think it's platform dependent as well. I use Twitter a lot in work. And I engage a lot with women in tech on Twitter.
But the women in tech hashtag can sometimes just be added to say, the sharing of an article about a woman. And then it's women in tech. Well, yeah, it is. But it's not anything to do with this woman. She's just, she's just a woman doing a job.
She's just a woman doing a job. Yeah, that's just me. I get paid to do this. Yeah, that's really cool.
I get torn when I hear the word women in tech. There are times when I think, oh, yay, they're talking about something really important.
Or they need to talk about something which is very relevant to women in tech. And oftentimes when it's just used as a hashtag, it's just used so that companies are at the forefront that this is what we're doing for women on this particular day.
And then just fades away during the rest of the year. And then it makes me wonder, is this word another one of those fun words people throw around because they want to be included or they want to show that they're being inclusive endeavors?
And are they actually doing something about it? So there are times that I've seen really good stuff come out of the when people say the word women in tech.
And then there are times when I'm like, no, this doesn't fit in here. Don't use it as much.
Well, it's a fully back right on buzzwords, particularly for International Women's Day, but it's a cliched phrase in a lot of sentences, but quite literally deeds, not words.
It's so powerful. Have a company that the company policy is to support women.
Don't just put hashtag women in tech on each other page. Yes. That's not enough.
We need actual help. Yeah. We don't just need a hashtag.
No. I'll take a hashtag, but I'd like more as well. Yeah.
Please give me more. Yeah.
Yeah. You see so many of these lists as well from companies who are like, here are the top 10 women in tech.
Here are the top 10 women in web security. And it's like, okay, thanks for the list.
But what are you doing like for these women to support their work?
You've compiled a essentially Buzzfeed article. Yeah. Yeah.
You've got a list to call. That's great. Yeah.
How can we make this the top 100 or top 1000? How can we add? That's the whole point, right?
Maybe we have the top 10, but what about the rest? Yeah. How do we make this list bigger? That's the point.
And how do we get more women able to be on a path to get them towards that as well? Yeah.
I do. I do consider myself a woman in tech. Even though I'm not in a technical role as such.
I think that working at the Daily Swig, we have to understand a lot of technical work.
I mean, to a certain point. But I'm not from a traditional tech background.
But I do definitely see myself as a woman in tech. I feel a sense of pride in being a woman in tech.
I think that it, for me, is a term that encompasses a lot of roles, not just your computer scientists and women with actual degrees.
So, yeah, I would say that I'm a non-technical woman in tech.
Nice. For me, I have a very different perspective. I consider myself a person at work rather than a woman in tech.
I mean, the job I do wouldn't change, whether it's a male or a female or anyone else, respectively of the gender doing it.
It means doing and I'm glad I have the opportunity to do it.
I come into work not thinking I'm a woman in tech. I come into work thinking I've got a good day ahead of me.
Yeah.
Probably it's based on the fact that the phrase didn't exist when I started my career, maybe.
It didn't play a part in how I approached my career.
I do what I do because this is what I want to do, rather than I do this because I want to bridge the gap or I want to help the society or whatever.
There are no big aspirations there. I just want to do what I like to do.
So probably a little bit controversial there. Not to say I'm not proud of being that minority.
I'll stand proud and I'll say I'll shout for mountain stops if it helps others.
If it can encourage one other person to take up and, you know, take that first step into this industry, I'd happily do it.
I'm really proud of that. But it doesn't impact my day to day life.
I like that perspective, actually. Just you don't think of yourself as a woman in tech. You think of yourself as a woman going to do your job.
That's it.
I do really like that. But I guess the, not challenge as such, but the fact that you're in an environment now where you're able to consider yourself like that.
I guess that's the next tier up for women in tech.
Possibly. I'm possibly in that sweet spot, so I don't need to think of this.
Yeah.
I can appreciate that for a lot of women. It's not the same.
That says a lot for the growth of the industry though. I think that there are women who are comfortable considering themselves simply people going about their roles in tech.
And it wouldn't matter. The output is indifferent based on gender, which I think is really powerful.
I think it's the end goal, really, to just exist without having to almost prove yourself and put yourself in a box and be like, this is who I am.
I am a woman in tech to just be someone enjoying the job and doing a good job at it.
And just being irrespective of gender.
You've climbed on top of the box.
Yeah.
That's impressive.
You own the box.
Maybe I created my own. I have no idea.
Maybe there's lots of stuff happening I'm ignoring and standing on my box.
That's it.
Not that it's a soapbox. Let's put that one right out there.
Just a box.
Thank you.
Just stood on a box.
I think the only thing I'd add to this wonderful conversation, which already you all have had, it's just, I think when I came across the term women in tech, I was not entirely confident in saying that I am a woman in tech.
And that happened because of a couple of incidents when we attended some conferences or started introducing ourselves because I'm in a non-technical role as well.
And someone would ask me, so are you a woman in tech because you're here at this conference or you're doing this event or you're interviewing because of this?
And I said, yes, I am.
And he's like, so what is your technical role?
I said, well, I'm not a technical woman in tech.
I work in a tech industry.
And I said, yeah, but technically should people should be in this role or a woman in tech.
And I felt a bit excluded.
And it took me a while to embrace the fact that no, because I work in this industry, I work in the world of tech.
I am a woman in tech.
So for me, the phrase resonates differently, perhaps to how it does to you because of the experiences I've had or because of my non-tech role being a woman in tech.
That's interesting that you were still shoehorned into a specific category even within this broader expression as well.
That shows there's probably still a lot to do, really.
My role is really balanced in that it encompasses some technical aspects and some non-technical.
From a traditional perspective, I'm not a developer.
I'm not a programmer, but I do build web pages.
I have interaction with developers.
So I think I would consider myself a woman in tech.
Maybe one day I'll learn JavaScript.
Big goal.
One day.
One day over there.
Yeah.
I definitely think that the phrase women in tech can be, can exclude women in non-technical roles for sure.
Even though I've said I do consider myself a woman in tech, I also sometimes feel excluded.
Mainly when I'm going to conferences and I meet other women in tech, as you said, and they are like, they're pen testers or they work in like cloud security.
And they're talking about all of these things that they do.
And I'm just like, I'm a journalist.
In a technical company.
I definitely do feel an almost hesitation sometimes when talking to these people.
I often caveat my own role and my own expertise with, I'm not technical, but I am a tech journalist.
Um, and I don't know.
I don't know why I feel like that.
There's not been any specific experience that I've had where someone's told me that I'm not a woman in tech.
Um, but there's just a general feeling sometimes that I get where I'm a bit hesitant to put it out there.
Um, and almost sometimes, almost a little bit ashamed of not fulfilling the technical, like CV of a tech worker.
Um, but I don't know if that's my own issues.
I'd agree.
I, I feel similarly.
My, my background's in English literature, in writing poetry.
That's, that, that's not the same.
It's not the same as writing code.
It's a completely different mindset.
And it, it's hard to feel like your contributions are valid.
I think I don't always feel comfortable, like putting myself out there to ask the question and just go, I don't, I don't understand.
I don't know what this means.
I can understand it.
It's not that I'm incapable.
I just don't right now.
So I think confidence, having the confidence to feel comfortable, just saying, I accept, I don't know this.
I'm really interested to learn.
And it's, I think that's what's so important about being in an environment where you can ask those questions.
Indeed.
You can, you can highlight not necessarily your ignorance, but the fact that you haven't had the opportunity to learn that yet.
And I think that's the balance for me is it's not just saying I'm ignorant and I will continue being that way.
It's going, no, I'm not ignorant.
I just, I haven't learned it yet.
It's there for me to learn.
I think it's really important to remember as well that nobody knows everything about web security.
Like who knows every single aspect of it.
It's so multifaceted.
No one knows everything.
There are always gaps in people's knowledge.
I might know something that you don't and vice versa.
There's always knowledge to be shared.
And the industry is evolving so quickly as well as new technologies constantly.
So it's so fast paced.
I can add a slightly different perspective to this if it helps.
I'm in a technical role, but I don't write any code.
But I do consider myself technical enough because I know I can do my job well.
And this doesn't come from pride.
It's with all the modesty I can gather right now.
I can say it's what's needed to be successful in your job.
It doesn't matter whether you can write code or whether you've got a degree to support the fact that whether you're technical or not technical.
My degree is in economics.
It's got nothing to do with what I do right now at work.
But I still feel, yes, I do fall into that category of being a woman in tech,
although I don't recognize it myself every day.
I do fall into that category.
So I guess there's a slightly different perspective to look at it.
So that's really interesting.
There is so many different roles as well in a tech company that need to be fulfilled.
Exactly.
If everybody was writing code, there'd be nobody to, I don't know, market the product.
There'd be nobody to speak to the customers.
It just wouldn't work.
And I think what's interesting about all of our roles is that they are wildly different, but they're just as important.
We have so much going on at Portsviga, from the actual products to the actual politics that we sell, to the Academy, to the Women in Tech Scholarship, to the Daily Swig.
There's so many different parts of it that you can't just have technical workers.
Like it just wouldn't work.
And this is the point I'm trying to make, that we should all be very proud of the work we do.
Yeah, I agree.
Without us, a lot wouldn't happen.
That's true.
That's interesting.
Very true.
A lot would not happen without us.
That's a nice sense of power, actually.
Yeah.
That makes me feel more comfortable with my contribution.
I like that perspective.
Thank you for that.
Thank you.